yeah charlie morton fastball curveball
pitcher that's all he needs he has a
little sink a little cut to that
fastball
and this one popped up right at second
albee's drifts back no need for galoshes
he makes the play
one out base is empty a shift on for him
as morton turns it loose and another
pop-up this one to freddie freeman
he's in the middle of the infield dirt
two up two down
on the ground into the shift riley will
charge that ball rolled up on him a bit
but he stayed with it to make the play
and charlie morton has an efficient one
two three first he needed just 11
pitches
and now josiah gray gets atlanta on his
resume tonight and solaire with 15
homers
rips one toward left center field that
ball's got a chance to go
there's a solo home run atlanta leads it
and that's the first mistake by the
young man celae is a fastball hitter
don't challenge me says celery he goes
yaya
man
what a way to start this game off man
talk about being on time for the fast
ball he brushed him off the plate up and
in
last pic before the fastball down the
middle and solaire just did not miss
a 424-foot missile
big story freddie freeman
has just come out of this game
he swung the bat three-and-oh
flight out to center and
cannot continue
that ball ripped and josh bell
extra bases deep into the left field
corner
duval digging it out and bell in the
second standing up
ozzy to his right clean throw gets him
out of the inning and it does a leadoff
double wasted by the nationals braves
lead one nothing middle of the second
heading to the bottom of the second
inning in atlanta braves one of the
nationals nothing
got him
steady diet of sliders there to dansby
swanson
great o2 slider wow
wow
85 under his bat
four k's in a row three righties then
peterson
josiah dylan crew two tonight
runner to second top of the order coming
up
and he smokes one into right center
field vote was breaking back toward the
second base bank stephenson drops the
ball now they're gonna wave vote home
belly flop in his second safe and a run
is in good piece of hitting by ozzy
albee's breaking ball
you see him right behind this ball
staying down with those legs sinking
down giving him a little bit more time
to adjust
vogt had to go back because of the shift
so that was a good play by vote and then
stevenson rushes in the outfield doesn't
understand the situation charlie horton
is back to work he's been dealing for
the braves hernandez bounced out his
first time he hits a one hopper ozzy two
long throws there's one and there's two
morton needed that a double play
as bell hits one softly in the air to
left twilight no problem for duvall he's
got that lead off single wasted for
washington bottom of the fourth it'll be
swanson duval and peterson for the
braves atlanta leading two-nothing
that one down the left-field line that
one's fair and headed for the corner
here it's a danger leading off the
fourth inning for atlanta
his 28th two bay's hit he keeps on
sizzling fellas when there are scoring
opportunities out there and that's a big
time fastball there
number eight for gray
fastball
up peterson the left center stevenson's
there
runner tags swanson to third
but the big deal is two down
right field
para
catches the foul ball
and josiah gray pretty good lesson last
two innings of limiting damage heading
for the bottom of the fifth in atlanta
braves two of the nationals nothing now
the wine of the pitch fastball swung on
and miss running up and in
adriana can move it tough guy to get in
a double play did he swing
it looks like john lipka punched him out
from third and he did
double digit strikeouts
for josiah gray
solera on the move fastball jammed him
hey not a strikeout but a really good
pitch
easy for stevenson and for the second
straight time josiah gray gives up one
earned run
over five innings as an end
and two walks to start the sixth
that ball's well hit
left center
line moving for the nats adams to third
soto to second
and the table is set for yaddio
hernandez
no balls to strike swing and a miss
blowing right by 95 miles an hour
second strike out of the inning sixth in
the game and did morton ever need that
he did and he got him
charlie martin strikes out the side
washington loads him up they cannot
score
luke jackson's the next pitcher in for
atlanta as we go to the eighth he had a
great inning last night struck out the
side now he's going to see a seventh
pitch from jackson but that'll take care
of him a swing and a miss
fair ball left field line
it'll hit the short wall there
and victor robles continues the nats
good pinch hitting lately
and that's well hit but right there is
swanson
high fly ball deep left back goes duval
to the warning track spins the wrong way
and he got it at the 375 side
oh baby that was close
another three feet that ball was curling
toward the bullpen wall and washington
out of luck in the eighth will smith
eight for eight in saves with a two-run
lead
and he did not chase
from o2 to a leadoff walk
breaking ball hit hard and down the left
field line
[Applause]
bell sliding into third
ryan zimmerman
and the pinch hitting continues
[Applause]
well played by riley to the pitcher
nats are on the board as bell scores
and the tying run ryan zimmerman 90 feet
away
[Music]
in the air to left
deep left field
see
you
later upper deck
how about that for your first hit as a
washington national that was a bomb
and they have turned the crowd
silent
the rookies first big league home run
happens on the road and he's mobbed in
the dugout meanwhile the new pitcher is
kyle finnegan
he'll make his 47th appearance with a
four and three record a 3.07 eri 11
holds and two saves in four tries
this one to the right side
bell
finnegan close
nets win
and the nationals have beaten the braves
here with three in the ninth